scar destin alors vous pouvez poser vos
questions partager vos souvenirs
partagés nous vos réactions vos dommages
éventuels également on les partagera
avec jean louis bourlanges bonjour
bonjour et bon l'orge vous avez côtoyé
valéry giscard d'estaing vous avez été
vous êtes actuellement député des
hauts-de-seine mais vous avez été une
figure de l'udf qui a été fondée par bus
jusqu'à 20 les giscard d'estaing et vous
l'avez côtoyé dites moi si je ne me
trompe mais lors de la fameuse aventure
de l'écriture sur la constitution
européenne
oui j'étais pas membre de la convention
au sens strict du terme mais j'étais
membre de la commission
constitutionnelle du parlement européen
et nous avions contribué énormément à un
volet important qui était la hiérarchie
des normes
enfin c'était d'aider dosage subtil et
j'avais beaucoup travaillé avec lui dans
les années qui précèdent
quand c'est quand nous avons été élus
ensemble sur deux listes différentes il
y avait la sienne
moi j'avais été élu sur la liste veille
et là on sait très bien où on s'est très
bien entendu intellectuellement au
parlement européen parce que il aimait
bien l'idée que non seulement qu'on
faisait l'europe mais qu'ont essayé de
réfléchir à ce qu'on faisait alors vous
allez nous raconter tout ça je signale
également que vous avez été le
contributeur dans ce livre de les
grandes figures de la droite de la
révolution française à nos jours c'est
un livre qui a été réalisé sous la
direction de jean christophe buisson du
figaro magazine et guillaume tabard
chroniqueur au figaro
vous avez été celui qui a réalisé
justement le chapitre sur valéry giscard
d'estaing on va y revenir
on va revenir dans un instinct également
sur la notamment sur les grands livres
7,1 et votre chapitre est un très bon
livre justement vous allez vous allez
comprendre pourquoi vous poser dans
toutes vos questions à jean louis
bourlanges vous allez pouvoir également
poser vos questions à eric roussel qui
est le biographe de valéry giscard
d'estaing auteur de valéry giscard
d'estaing cette édition de
l'observatoire y va nous rejoindre
il est en route auparavant je vous
propose de revenir sur les dernières
infos tout ce qu'on a appris depuis hier
soir et en particulier depuis ce matin
avec vous pierre piler le président donc
je vais la giscard d'estaing s'était
officiellement des suites de la commune
c'est une précision apportée par sa
famille dans un communiqué transmis à
nos confrères de l' agence france-presse
ses obsèques donc on se dérouler dans la
plus stricte intimité familiale c'est
une autre information qui nous est
parvenu on rappelle que vge cet état
entourée des siens dans sa propriété
dotons dans le loir-et-cher commune
village de 700 habitants entre blois et
tour autre information à retenir ce
matin est bien c'est que emmanuel macron
s'adressera aux français ce soir 20h
pour un hommage à vge 1 c'est ce
qu'indique l'elysée sa mort est un deuil
pour la nation française écrivait dès
hier soir le président de la république
dans un communiqué saluant un septennat
qui transforma la france conséquence de
cette allocution de ce soir emmanuel
macron décale son interview chez nos
confrères de brut prévue aujourd'hui
elle se déroulera finalement demain
après midi
les réactions les réactions à l'étranger
afflux l'allemagne perd un ami c'est ce
qu'a déclaré il ya quelques minutes sa
chancelière angela merkel 1 ce matin là
la presse outre-rhin rappelle les liens
entre vge et le chancelier helmut
schmidt ce couple franco-allemand vge
helmut schmidt deux hommes qui ont
concrétisé leur rêve d'une europe plus
intégrée voilà ce qu'on peut lire sur le
compte twitter du président du conseil
européen charles michel qui présente ses
condoléances au peuple français tout
comme ursula von der leyen la présidente
de la commission européenne aujourd'hui
nous pleurons un grand européen qui
continuera de nous inspirer
voilà vous allez voir son tweet posté en
français dans son coeur les destins de
la france et de l'europe étaient
étroitement liées
le conseil européen jean louis
bourlanges d'ailleurs c'est une
institution qui avait été voulue et
porté par il avait considéré que je
taperai avons travaillé que le conseil
des ministres c'est à dire les mini f1
étrangères valéry giscard d'estaing a
considéré que les responsabilités
européennes étaient trop importantes
pour que ce ne soit pas les responsables
politiques de premier plan
c'est à dire soit les présidents de la
république pour nous notamment soient
les premiers ministres qui siègent et
c'était une réponse très importante à
ses yeux à à l'accusation de déficit
démocratique parce que les gens qui sont
là autour du conseil européen
c'est ce qu'ils endossent
la volonté du père volonté de chaque
peuple était moins partisan de la
formule de la commission oui alors c'est
une moitié c'est un des rares des
accords que j'ai eue avec lui je pense
que ça s'explique par le fait qu'il
était qu'il a fonctionné dans une europe
assez étroites en termes de nombre et
que donc il pouvait considérer que le
conseil européen était quasiment un
gouvernement mais dans une europe à 28
le conseil européen c'est une assemblée
et il faut une commission et hiérarchisé
avec une présidente ou un président des
vice présidents et pour que ça
fonctionne pour avoir un véritable
gouvernement européens ça il a eu du mal
à l'admettre et c'est dommage il a très
bien compris le rôle du conseil européen
très bien compris le rôle du parlement
européen très bien compris le rôle du
conseil des ministres pas celui de la
commission peut-être ça s'explique par
le fait qu'il avait été chef d'état
parlementaire européen ministre
l'économie mais qu'il n'a jamais été
membre de la commission
vous confirmez en tous les cas que
beaucoup de fédéralistes on vous laisse
car des stands juste alors pour cette
critique à l'encontre de cette
institution de la commission européenne
vient on revient en france parmi des omh
ce matin il ya eu celui du premier
ministre jean castex moi qui voit en
giscard un homme de progrès et de
liberté dont les réformes de société
restent d'une profonde actualité et puis
il ya cette question une question et si
le musée d'orsay prenait finalement le
nom de valéry giscard d'estaing s'est en
tout cas l'appel lancé ce matin par
rachida dati la maire les républicains
du 7e arrondissement arrondissement dans
lequel se trouve le prestigieux édifice
culturel appel relayé par valérie
pécresse la présidente de la région ile
de france qui estime que valéry giscard
d'estaing a transformé en cette gare
d'orsay ans l'un des musées les plus
visités au monde à la gloire de nos
impressionniste très vite et très très
bonne idée venue de l'approuver
l'anecdote d'ailleurs sur le musée
d'orsay c'est que il
moment de son inauguration il avait été
invité par françois françois mitterrand
et que la responsable de musée d'orsay
s'agisse car le savez était anne pingeot
la mère de lasagnes par jeu d'une
galerie en tout cas de la galerie des
sculptures donc ça n'a jamais empêché la
même page ou d'être un excellent
fonctionner et effectivement giscard
d'estaing de garder cette discrétion
d'autres dons que là on suivra la on
suivra la locution donc de démêler le
maquereau ce soir à 20 heures
et on est bien sûr à l'affût des
dernières informations notamment sur la
date des obsèques pour l'instant on ne
l'a pas la plus stricte intimité
familiale c'est tout ce qu'on sait à
l'heure actuelle et puis donc et
allocutions des mâconnais
on va avoir une cible une dichotomie une
séparation entre les obsèques avaient dû
à colombes et des églises avec
uniquement les compagnons de la
libération
et puis la grande cérémonie officielle
notre dame on va donc avoir sans doute à
un modèle de ce genre c'est votre
cerveau de paris où c'est une
information assez mon pari c'est bon
mais c'est même pas mon pari c'est un
pronostic je crois quand même que la
france au président de la république et
corps constitués devront se réunir pour
rendre hommage au président jusqu'à
destin donc comme l'otc les obsèques se
feront dans l'intimité pour cause
d'intimité et de kovy de réuni faudra
bien inventer quelque chose comme ça eh
bien on va suivre merci beaucoup en tout
cas pierre pour ces précisions
eric roussel va nous rejoindre pardon et
vous pouvez me poser de galles dans
toutes les questions sur la vie de
giscard d'estaing c'est lui le biographe
de l'ancien président du troisième
président de la vème république
alors comme le président carter aux
états unis jusqu'à a été longtemps
considéré comme le meilleur ancien
président français c'était avant la
défaite de nicolas sarkozy en 2012 avant
le retrait de la course à la
présidentielle de françois hollande
et finalement comme le raconte charles
jaigu c'est un destin qui a été souvent
dominés par les regrets
ce sera toujours un regret pour pour
giscard d'estaing de ne pas avoir
reconquis la l'elysée la présidence de
république mais au fond il sera pas le
seul ils sont très nombreux et enfin
très non pas si nombreux mais enfin c c
on sait que revenir en politique même en
france c'est quand même un sport
difficile
le handicap de giscard d'estaing a été
au fond de réussir trop jeune il a
réussi très jeune et il est donc a été
il a été président de république à la
retraite à 55 ans et au fond il fallait
qu'ils se trouvent une une deuxième
vocation politique il n'a jamais réussi
à concrétiser ses ambitions ni en 88 où
s'ébat raymond barre pour pour sa
famille politique qui a mené le combat
né en 1995 où c'est edouard balladur qui
a mené le combat à sa place ni ensuite
parce qu'il était déjà trop vieux
finalement on peut dire que toutes ces
années ont été difficiles pour lui mais
il aura quand même réussi à incarner une
chose qui comptait vraiment beaucoup à
ses yeux c'était une certaine idée de
l'europe
[Musique]
et cette idée de l'europe un homme l'a
bien connu qui a été ministre des
affaires européennes ministre des
affaires étrangères c'est hervé de
charette bonjour nous entendez mais je
vous entends très bien avec charrette
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
direct vous êtes jour on le disait un
ancien ministre des affaires étrangères
et européennes
vous avez été là une figure de l'udf et
surtout ami on a eu une coupure on va on
va y revenir dans un instant on va
revenir dans un instant jean louis
bourlanges sur l'europe
ça a été vous allez nous l'avait déjà
dit ça a été l'une des grandes
déceptions de giscard ça a été l'autre
grande déception après les élections la
défaite à l'élection présidentielle de
1981 ça a été la la défaite
en tous les cas la victoire du non à la
constitution européenne au référendum de
2005 le nom un projet qui avait été
porté par vers giscard d'estaing comme
moi par exemple je me rappelle très bien
on a eu le sentiment par un plat
sciences po où j'étais et je fais la
cour qui était énormément de succès un
an après il y avait beaucoup moins de
monde ça a été un coup d'arrêt est un
coup d'arrêt qui n'est pas imputable à
giscard je veux dire que quand vous
voyez ce que les français disent sur le
traité de maastricht sur le traité
constitutionnel
en réalité leurs critiques portent sur
le traité de rome sur les dispositions
qui ont été introduites par valéry
giscard d'estaing dans le cadre du
traité constitutionnel ce qui rendait
d'ailleurs le système de noms à gérable
parce que vous ne pouviez pas tenir
compte vraiment des objections du nom
s'en sortir de l'union européenne or les
partisans du non disait non on veut
rester mon voeu que ce soit autrement
les anglais sont plus cohérents ils ont
dit nous ça nous plaît pas on va en des
parties alors on me dit qu'avec
charrette est revenu
bonjour hervé de charette vous
connaissez le ces questions européennes
ou à lesterps anciens ministres affaires
étrangères et européennes sous jacques
chirac avant d'y revenir
quels souvenirs vous aujourd'hui vous
gardez de verre giscard d'estaing le
souvenir le plus marquant et vous dire
que quand on regarde l'histoire laser
game republic sûr mais à part le cas
comment dire exceptionnelle de du
général de gaulle je pense que giscard a
été sans contestation possible plus
grands présidents de la vème république
il a marqué l'histoire à la fois parce
que d'abord il a on lui doit sabilité de
la constitution d'un cinquième en public
s'il n'avait pas été là c'est mitterrand
il est disparu dans l'instant elle
n'aurait été qu'un court moment de
l'histoire mais au contraire jusqu'à
montrer l'importance qu'il attachait ou
fait qu'on ne touche pas la constitution
maintenant on la change tous les trois
mois qu'on ne touche pas aux textes qui
le tire et ramène son mandat sans qu'une
virgule ont été modifiés il a été aussi
l'homme qui a été direct le
modernisateur de la vie politique
française tout le monde l'a 10 à 5 en
pagne électorales de 1974 c'était un
truc formidable à l'américain de 18 ans
en tout cas complètement modernisé
renouvelables aussi tout ce qu'on lui
doit d'en pratiquer dans la moyenne des
toits des pays et le développement
industriel le télescope et cetera
c'était vraiment une période assez
formidable et en même temps social et
européen sociale pourrait revenir dessus
parce qu'il est très important mais
européen sans le slogan de sa campagne
libérale social européen sait exactement
aujourd'hui ce que me semble-t-il la
france essaye de faire si j'ose vous le
dire je vous dirais macron aujourd'hui
c'est le cas du 20e
vous avez répondu à ma dernière question
je vous remercie comme ça qui était
l'héritier de giscard j'ai une autre
question hervé de charette a les deux
questions et je demande une réponse
brève
la première question c'est que vous
dites que ça a été le plus grand
président de la vème république
après le général de gaulle or vous avez
été ministre sous jacques chirac qui est
qui a lui fait deux mandats et qui a
fait deux mandats après françois
mitterrand alors en quoi
giscard d'estaing est à plus grands
présidents que ne l'ont été
françois mitterrand et jacques chirac et
puis peut-être avant que vous me
répondez à cette question moi je
voudrais vous me racontiez quelque chose
qui m'a toujours intrigué puisque
jacques chirac et valéry giscard
d'estaing on va y revenir avec eric ou
celle qui vient de nous rejoindre
ce décès se détester c'est l'une des
plus grosses fortunes n de l'histoire de
la vème république et vous avez été
l'artisan du soutien de valéry giscard
d'estaing à la campagne de jacques
chirac en 1995
comment vous avez vendu entre guillemets
l'idée de à giscard de soutenir son
ennemi intime écouter parce qu'il ya des
moments où il faut savoir tourner les
pages regardez comment giscard a été
battu il a été battu parce que d'abord
la politique politicienne ce n'est pas
vraiment centre n'était pas à l'aise il
ne met pas beaucoup
il faisait ce qu'il fallait aux douches
sais pas ce qu'il allait faire
mais c'était pas son ce pas tellement
son truc mais il a été battu parce que
lui ce qu'il voulait sasson thème
c'était la france souhaite gouverner au
centre
évidemment ils avaient en conséquence
contre lui une coalition politique andré
semblable entre la droite dure
d'un côté et la gauche dans sa diversité
et les uns et les autres ne voyez pas
d'issue politique pour eux s'ils ont
éliminé pagicien et donc il était
d'accord et d'ailleurs ils ont fait
campagne pratiquement ensemble pour
éliminer les chiens qu'est-ce que si
vous regardez la vie politique française
aujourd'hui le paysage politique n'est
pas très différent de cela en diamant
les hommes sont pas les mêmes
s'arrête hervé de charette parce que
justement vous avez raconté comment
chirac a été jusqu'à a été battu en 1981
justement par le coup de poignard selon
ce que vous dites de chirac commence
comment il a pu accepté en 1995 de
soutenir jacques chirac plutôt que de
soutenir edouard balladur qui était
idéologiquement plutôt sur sa ligne je
crois pas qu'on peut dire c'est que la
deuxième fois je suis pas vraiment
d'accord mais par contre sur le premier
point je vais vous dire je pense que ça
va ça n'a pas été facile c'était pas
c'était comment dirais-je était d'un
acte extrêmement vertueux de sa part et
je me souviens très bien des heures que
nous avons passées ensemble des moments
de tension que nous avons eues lui et
moi ensemble sur ce point et finalement
je lui suis reconnaissant et je lui
rends hommage pour avoir eu l'audace
politique mais surtout le courage
personnel
la vertu personnel pour soutenir la
campagne de chirac auquel il avait en
effet beaucoup de reproches à faire
merci vous couvrir de moi même j'ai
participé à cette campagne et qui ont
été ensuite dans son gouvernement
ce qui va vous ce qui vous a valu d'être
ministre de jacques chirac
un dernier point vous considérez pas que
du coup jacques chirac a été le plus
grand président de la vème république
non non non non non chirac avait des
qualités des vertus mais on peut pas
dire qu'il a été le plus grand président
et un arrêt de plus sûrement pas
personne ne dirait ça merci beaucoup
le plus sympathique atteinte à l'égard
oui ça a sûrement le plus grand nom
merci merci beaucoup hervé de charette
merci pour ce témoignage et merci pour
avoir été en direct avec vous on sera en
direct tout à l'heure avec dominique
bussereau je rappelle que vous avez été
donc proche de valéry giscard d'estaing
et ancien ministre affaires étrangères
et européennes eric roussel bonjour à
charette a tourné autour du pot il n'a
pas dit pourquoi jacques chirac
un quart des saints a soutenu son ennemi
intime
en 1995 on disait que c'était parce
qu'il avait peur que balladur vol l'udf
oui je crois que c'est une hypothèse oui
effectivement il s'était un peu choix de
au fond de la deûle a raison il était
oui faut quand même pas oublier qu'ils
s'étaient déjà réconciliés sous les
auspices du général de bénouville autour
d'un bar grillé ce n'est sous mitterrand
donc voilà je crois que c'est il faut
dire que c'était quand même le la
configuration vous décrivez elle était
déjà présente en 88 c'est à dire qu'il
n'a pas vraiment soutenu raymond barre
alors on peut avoir les explications que
d'un hervé de charette
on peut avoir une explication pisam sait
qu'en politique les gens dont vous êtes
les plus proches ne sont pas forcément
ceux qu'on a envie de soutenir le plus
ardemment et comment se fait-il qu'en
1988 il se fait doubler par raymond
barre et qui n'arrivent pas se
représenter contre françois mitterrand
parce que raymond barre avait réussi à
apparaître comme quelqu'un de il avait
une image de compétence qu'il avait
acquis durant son passage au pouvoir
et puis peut-être été moins exposée
encore qu'il est polarisée évidemment
certain nombre de critiques dues à sa
gestion d' assez sévères il y avait il
avait acquis l'image d'un homme n'est
pas un homme neuf
enfin il avait moi il était et puis
surtout il n'avait pas été défaits séoul
et le le fait quand même d'avoir été
battu quelque chose qui est jusqu'à
entraîner
je crois que je crois que là il faut
quand même pas sous-estimer c'est la
question que nous nous posions tout à
l'heure c'est extrêmement dur de faire
un retour un come back comme on dit en
bon français de faire un come-back quand
on a été battus c'est possible de
revenir quand on a démissionné comme le
général de gaulle en 46 c'est c'est
possible c'est possible quand le mandat
s'est terminé comme raymond poincaré qui
à l'issue et c'était le grand modèle de
valéry giscard d'estaing qui avait été
président de la république il est
redevenu président du conseil mais il
est évident que les français en 80 avait
envie de tourner la page et la
formidable popularité de raymond barre
elle s'explique qu'il n'a pas su
d'ailleurs géré très bien politiquement
mais elle s'explique par là et valéry
giscard d'estaing à mon avis c'est le
seul reproche je lui en ai parlé
d'ailleurs en 95
c'est le seul reproche que je lui fais
n'a pas n'a pas suffisamment été fidèle
à cette idée qu'il y avait une famille
libérale sociale européenne qui était la
sienne et qui a vu qu'il ya eu
successivement avec des différences
comme porte-parole raymond barre et
edouard balladur il n'a pas convoqué
hier le choc de l'arrivée de jusqu'à
l'arrivée de chirac a été quand même un
bouleversement total pour le centre est
pour le giscardisme un bouleversement
total il ya une chose que vous dites et
crucell c'est que c'est un président mal
aimé
c'est un président mal connu est ce que
finalement il n'y a pas un syndrome chez
giscard c'est qu'ils pensaient qu'il
avait des choses qui devaient s'imposer
d'évidence par exemple affaire des
diamants ne devait pas en parler parce
que d'évidence c'était une affaire qui
était dérisoire
d'évidence c'était lui qui était
l'incarnation de la figure européenne de
la figure centriste et que ça devait
être lui qui devait être choisi que
finalement il a laissé passer des trains
devant ceux de vence est devant cette
estime à cause de l estime de soi trop
forte
oui on peut dire ça comme ça on peut
dire aussi avec j'arrête là l'a bien dit
tout à l'heure c'était quelqu'un qui
n'avait pas de goût pour la politique du
non politicienne seul
à certains égards c'est une comparaison
qui peut paraître bizarre mais il se
rapprochait de calcul comme
mendès-france s'étaient tous les deux la
défense était aussi un homme d'idées de
projets s'étaient pas les mêmes
évidemment mais il avait il se
proclamait parlementariste mais quand il
s'est agi de rénover le parti radical
essayons pas dire que ce soit pris d'une
façon très très astucieuse et les
giscard était un peu comme ça ils
n'avaient pas eu d'effet
il fait enfin nous sommes pas d'accord
c'est qu'il ait pas d'accord oui oui
enfin il me semble moins jeune et j'ai
vu ça de l'extérieur je n'étais pas je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas la même expérience
que jean louis bourlanges
mais il me semble qu'ils n'avaient pas
le qu'il n'avait pas beaucoup de goût
pour ce
pour ce genre d'affaires et qui en
général ils avaient plutôt pour habitude
de l'est sous traitée en fin du mois
sous de gros sous de gaulle et pompidou
souvent c'était des gens comme michel
poniatowski et qui se chargeait de la
sous traiter la sphère est lui-même
donc je pense que ça explique aussi et
il pensait effectivement ils avaient une
vue c'est giscard c'est quand même une
intelligence de polytechniciens
d'ingénieurs il est donc ils pensaient
que des à partir du moment où les choses
étaient évidentes elles devaient elles
devaient s'imposer c'était quand même un
peu à peu son idée il était inconnu
jusqu'à les saints dans les années 60
mais j'ai lu eric roussel et quand on
lit eric roussel on s'aperçoit que
c'était un très habile homme politique
la façon dont il s'est imposé d'abord
vous citez d'ailleurs le leu leu leu son
slogan quand il fait sont se recentre
son papier pour être élu en 56 ans à ce
circonscription il ya un espèce de
papier d'une simplification et d'une
efficacité folie dans mes folies mais
c'est à ces quatre trucs enfin il dit
voilà si vous avez c'est totalement
simplifier c'est le contraire de
l'intellectuel que tordu etc
il est très efficace et toute sa gestion
de sa sortie de du ministère jusqu'à son
arrivée au pouvoir il ya bien sûr des
erreurs il ya une erreur notamment ça
vraiment 68 quand il
il propose de voter contre la censure de
peut voter la censure du bon enfin il
invite le gouvernement pompidou avec a
quitté la scène ça c'est une maladresse
mais globalement il est extrêmement
habile mais en revanche ce que je veux
dire c'est que s'il est battu en 81
c'est normal et ça alors parce que en
réalité les forces économiques et
sociales ne lui permettait pas de gagner
votre relire dans les grandes figures de
la droite
à lire également avec la biographie de
valéry giscard d'estaing dont l'auteur
et eric roussel c'est que l'église le
livre chapitre sur de gaulle et derrick
russel elle dit juste je vous coupe mais
la thèse que défend jean louis
bourlanges dans ce chapitre c'est à dire
que finalement contrairement à ce qu'on
a ce qu'on a dit ce n'est pas la
trahison chiraquienne qui l'a battu en
1981 et qui a contribué ce qui a battu
ce qui est belle oui mais vous vous
dites que même si les gaullistes avaient
tous voté d'extrême droite aussi c'est
déjà vrai qui est haché indiscutable il
aurait été battu même s'il y avait une
mobilisation à droite oui je crois mais
d'ailleurs c'est logique quand vous
partez de 74 vous voyez qu'il est élu
avec une très petite majorité
et si on avait fait voter les jeunes
gens entre 18 et 21 ans
les sondages pas ça se serait passé
comme ça mais les sondages montrent
comité aurait été élu or il change le
mode de scrutin
il ya un million de chômeurs il ya les
deux et il ya les deux chocs pétroliers
il est dans une situation et on n'a pas
vu venir les nos explications se
combinent je crois qu'il ya des causes
disant structurelles et des causes
conjoncturelles dans cette ça ce ça se
recoupent
et quand jean louis bourlanges dit
qu'effectivement qui faisait preuve de
sens politique
mais ça veut pas dire pour autant que la
gestion c'est une chose d'avoir une
sorte de flers et ça ils avaient
évidemment ils détestent d'un grand
fauve
mais la gestion d'un parti je vais dire
au jour le jour ce que mu ce que
mitterrand parce vous savez faire entrer
dans le who's who chirac avec tout ce
que ça suppose de plutôt de fausses
camaraderie ça franchement je crois pas
que jusqu'à était vraiment dans son rôle
quand il faisait ça et c'est tout même
quelque chose qu'ils ont et madrid
mitterrand oui enfin il était géré à ça
non mais si oui est-ce qu'on se tutoie
qui comme vous voulez vous voulez si
vous voulez il savait gérer ça met les
mains dans ce genre de 2012 et 2 et de
séduction je suis escarpins griffés la
la campagne 80 était très mauvaise
c'est évident mais je crois que les
causes structurelles sont vraiment on a
un certain nombre de questions
d'internautes et je voudrais qu'on y
revienne
juste avant est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
paradoxe quand même chez giscard libéral
mais finalement un homme qui a augmenté
considérablement les impôts proche du
peuple
mes grands bourgeois moderne mais
monarchique venu de la droite dure et
finalement sociétalement de gauche dans
ses réformes
non je crois qu'il ya des choses qui
sont un petit peu réductrice les points
que vous êtes assez giscardien dans
notre réplique non alors peut-être
attendre il faudrait reprendre bien en
tout cas je dis libéral mais finalement
qui a augmenté les impôts rue louis
alors bon c'est sûr qu'il ya une raison
oui c'est sûr que le ouf on attendait
giscard sur le terrain où il était le
réputé être le plus performant le
malheur pour lui c'est qu'il ya deux
chocs pétroliers évidemment qui ont
augmenté de façon pratiquement
automatique les bons ils en étaient pas
ravi c'était pas c'était pas non plus là
il faut dire qu'il n'a pas une chance et
un peu que le président actuel il
c'est comme pour sa filiale chose une
chose précise là dessus il a refusé le
déficit c'est ça c'est ça le problème
c'est qu'il est il s'est trouvé
confronté à une crise qui appelait des
dépenses sociales de plus il a mené sa
c'est vrai votre interlocuteur a raison
de le dire
il a mené une politique sociale très
active il a notamment augmenté
massivement la retraite des vieux qui
sont sortis de l'indigence dans lequel
une grand grand nombre d'entre eux ont
été maintenus
il a développé la sécurité sociale pour
les agriculteurs les commerçants etc tu
as donc ça les chômeurs l'indemnisation
des chômeurs tout ça ça vient de lui et
ça a coûté cher et il a décidé ça
c'était le choix de raymond barre mais
qu'il a approuvé de ne pas faire
financer sa part le déficit quand vous
faites pas financée par des visites vous
augmentez les impôts
effectivement il s'est retrouvé dans une
situation contradictoire puisqu'il avait
lui-même dit qu'un pays qui avait plus
de 40 % de prélèvements obligatoires
était un pays socialiste
il a atteint je disais aux y aussi pour
c'est peut-être ça qui vous êtes
et qui vous est paru choquants
rédempteur en tout cas je venu de la
droite dure et finalement société de
gauche faut le dire par exemple un
internaute nous dit un homme brillant
mais un président de la république aux
choix politiques contestables bon ça
c'est la vie de cet internaute comme par
exemple sur l'avortement
ça vous est vrai que on a appris je ne
sais pas c'est veille ils avaient ils
s'étaient carrément 1074 pour se rallier
une partie de l'électorat qui était sur
sa droite celui de jean royer il promet
de ne pas légaliser la barre a donc non
il ya un honneur il ya un an il ya même
des déclarations je viens de participer
à une émission sur la france info où
justement il disait le contraire on le
voyait
et il disait au cours de la campagne qui
s'engageait non non ça c'est jean royer
mêlant risque à un type très bien mais
il y avait sans doute début des voix
mais oui je n'étais pas de ce monde
cet autre internaute ne dit je n'ai pas
connu vge mais j'ai l'impression que la
gauche a tout fait pour regard 10 et son
héritage
oui c'est tubuai la gauche n'a pas été
la seule c'est à dire qu'il s'est trouvé
sur tout ce que je vais faire je le
connaissais depuis 83 mais je vais
surtout pratiquée à la fin de sa vie si
vous voulez ce qui lui était désagréable
c'est qu'ils sentaient que l'évolution
du monde faisait qu' il était parti de
là lui qui s'était voulu moderne et au
fond sociologiquement il faisait partie
de l'ancien monde
c'était et c'est ce discours anti
élitiste qui c'est qui s'est développé
beaucoup ces dernières années évidemment
ils ont été la première victime parce
qu'il incarne l les élites à une puis à
la puissance 10 comme à la fois par son
origine sociale son parcours famille oui
oui oui il cherchait pas d'ailleurs à le
nier
maintenant il ya une question de ces
jouets proche du pca france et je ne
sais jamais défini à mon avis quand on
dit j'ai réagi quand on peut ce monsieur
parler de droite dure je vois pas très
bien il est la prestation de sa famille
dans ces eaux sombres et rui son père
113 son père et son père et père de la
nation française
oui il nourrit
mais je lui ai posé la question pendant
que je lui ai dit son père et avait des
convictions européennes ac qui a affirmé
je vais poser la question je lis mais
est-ce que ça votre engagement européen
doit quelque chose à votre père il a
hésité 2002 puis je vante encore sa
réponse des franchement non et il m'a
dit mon père était de culture
maurrassienne il était arrivé l'europe
enfin par d'autres biais moi c'est tout
à fait différent il est non il ne peut
pas le définir comme venant de la droite
dure c'est un grand tu dis bien que mal
souvent et c'est la référence en la
montagne pour lui c'est sa mère par sa
mère est à la fois républicaines et
gaullistes
elle dépend il descend il faut pas
oublier il descend d'un gêneur bardou
qui est un des fondateurs de la
troisième république
qui donc dans les grands combats du 19e
siècle la balle à la création de la
république et c est du bon côté si je
puis dire et son grand homme c'est
d'ailleurs éric le site ricochet le site
d'un son livre c'est seval des crous au
waldeck rousseau
c'est aussi un mets mes grands hommes il
est bien oubliée waldeck rousseau et
comme périphérie waldeck rousseau c'est
à dire c'est et républicains modérés
ils sont absolument pas des droits et
c'est ça du coup ça explique une partie
de la seule idole manque de la fragilité
de giscard et puis la fin de sa défaite
c'est que il représentait un courant
politique en france qui est traditionnel
ibera l'isthme de l'organisme qui
traditionnellement est faible en fin de
cahier qui n'a pas de est-ce que c'est
pas ça justement la réussite de giscard
c'est à dire que ça sent le coup il a
aussi à le transcender par sa part
souvent sous la dent personnel mais il
n'empêche que quand il a été quand il a
fallu tout de même seuls qui s'appuie
sur quelque chose ça a marché un peu en
78 social avec l'udf mais c'était quand
même fragile et faux pas rené rémond 10
et 3 droite droite de la partie sa
droite orléaniste la droite
en fait il ya la droite démocrate
chrétienne qui est en réalité la droite
démocrate y intel la droite libérale et
la moelle de la partie si vous voulez
réussir quand vous êtes quelqu'un comme
jusqu'à vous devez fédérer les
démocrates-chrétiens et les libéraux et
casser la droite de la partie
c'est ce qu'il a fait en 74 ans mettant
dans son camp chirac et les anciens
conseillers de pompidou et c'est ce qui
n'a pas réussi vraiment à faire en 81
malgré les conseils judicieux et non
suivies que lui avait données alain
peyrefitte
il nous reste il nous reste peu de temps
c'est passionnant mais nous avons de
temps pour pouvoir continuer la
discussion en lisant justement vovo
oeuvre à la fois dans les grandes
figures de la droite et dans la
biographie de valéry giscard d'estaing
and with nous dit l'endettement de la
france a commencé son son septennat
c'est ce que vous avez expliqué
justement avec le programme également de
la crise enfin essayer de combattre
contre hollande le déficit c'est ce que
vous dites c'est simple si vous
laissions des situations parle du
déficit budgétaire il existe au monde
barre si on part du déficit des finances
publiques non quand il quitte le pouvoir
les finances publiques les finances de
l'état et les finances sociales sont
globalement équilibrés d'un chouïa mais
après une montée en puissance de l'état
providence absolument prodigieux dont le
pays a été tenue a été tenue mais au
prix d'un très grand sacrifice de
notamment déclassé le gouvernement je
vais vous dire la chose c'est le
gouvernement le plus social démocrate
que la france ait jamais vues domitius
nous dit c'est malheureusement c'est
aussi c'est un point de vue c'est
malheureusement aussi lui qui a fait le
regroupement familial dans nos payons
encore les conséquences aujourd'hui là
aussi c'est un cetain c'est une opinion
ça mais moi j'ai eu une information qui
dit ça a été un de ses plus grands
regrets politique a dit le pen m le pen
monde
il m'en avait parlé effectivement il
avait il m'a dit qu'il croit que c'est
dans mon livre d'ailleurs qui regrettait
de ne pas avoir c'est chirac
formellement qui s'est fait par décret
et regrettait de ne pas avoir hissé été
assez attentif à j'avais fait un débat
avec lui à versailles il s'en était
expliqué aussi directement devant le
public
il ya deux ans et il avait aussi
expliqué qu'il y avait des bons il y
avait un contexte qui n'était pas qui
n'est pas du tout celui d'aujourd'hui il
faut dire aussi quand même que les bons
on a fait venir quand même beaucoup de
travailleurs immigrés c'est difficile de
donner 2 2 les priver complètement de
famille et puis il y avait quand même
des conditions très restrictives sous
sous giscard qui ont été complètement
annihilés quand mitterrand parce que je
coupe je vous redonne la parole juste
après mais dominique bussereau est en
ligne avec nous bonjour dominique
bussereau bonjour merci d'être avec nous
alors on vous entend sur toutes les
ondes depuis depuis hier soir c'est
normal vous êtes vous avez été une
figure des jeunes giscardiens vous dit
une chose à raconter quelque chose moi
qui m'a frappé c'est que la fameuse
phrase de giscard dans le débat face à
mitterrand en 1974
vous n'avez pas le monopole du coeur ne
vous avait pas marqué vous les jeunes
giscardiens quand elle a été prononcée
oui c'est vrai que sur le moment on a
regardé fait à la télévision l'été aux
nues le qg de campagne de giscard rue de
la bienfaisance dans le 8e
arrondissement de paris et on a trouvé
que c'était une très bonne répartie et
si vous voulez on en a pas c'est
l'utilisation qui en est faite encore 40
ans a plus après en disant que ça avait
fait bouger de quelques milliers d'oies
élections présidentielles présent
vétérans dizaine inverse comme d'autres
chez nous on dit après que ça fasse ça
fera sur le président du passif
concernant le président giscard
d'estaing 80 lui avait permis de gagner
je pense que c'est une manière de
réécrire l'histoire c'était une très
bonne réplique historique maintenant
c'est pas ça qui a fait qui a fait
changer l'élection il avait fait une
très bonne campagne a fait là
la première campagne moderne des années
70 il y avait un besoin de changement
avec une certaine continuité les
français n'étaient pas encore prêts
l'alternance politique comme ils le
furent en 1981 voilà donc ça fait bouger
les choses
mon avis ça ne les a pas
fondamentalement changé enfin le débat
n'est pas si important que cela
quelque chose qui est très marquant
quand on regarde la campagne de 1974
parce que on entend votre récit 2010
trop et d'autres qui ont participé et
pourtant c'est ce qu'a révélé le
cinéaste raymond depardon c'est que
jusqu'à a été centré seul dans cette
dans cette campagne et surtout seul le
soir sa victoire
on voit bien les images de pardon il est
au ministère des finances avec à un
petit radio à transistor de l'époque
mais tout seul il n'a pas de
collaborateurs pataterie pas de family
c'est vrai que nous étions tous
pardonnez moi j'ai un chat dans la gorge
vous êtes tous au qg de campagne et
jusqu'à on est venu qu'après lorsqu'il
est la certitude d'avoir gagné c'est
assez c'est ça arrive ça arrive que moi
je me rappelle d'élection de 8,2 du du
président chirac il avait voulu aussi
une partie de la soirée être seul parce
qu'il était très énervé une avant par le
fait d'être au deuxième tour avec jean
marie le pen
il avait des moments où nous quitter son
équipe de campagne avec jean pierre
raffarin nicolas sarkozy un autre encore
pour pour rester seul et et voilà est
jugé par lui même de ce qui se passait
eric roussel à propos du film de deux
pardon c'est assez anecdotique mais ça
m'a frappé je me demande si cette scène
reggae de
j'ai bussereau fait allusion n'a pas été
rejoué après coup parce qu'il ya un
détail qui est quand même assez curieux
c'est que le soir alors qu'il est il va
être élu président de la république
quand on voit ce qu'on voit sur son
veston
il a les insignes de grand-croix de la
légion d'honneur alors je pense pas
qu'ils les avaient préparés puisque son
soutien port illégal de décoration
regardez le film fait c'est parce que ça
lui être retourné après et qu'on a et
qu'on a oublié de retirer ce détail
n'est pas l'histoire c'est vrai que la
scène de solitude et giscard dans ce qui
sert des finances encore de la rue de
rivoli et très étonnant et les vois je
me rappelle de la soirée quand il est
arrivé à son qg de campagne à c'est
assez rigolo parce qu'on a vu arriver
tous les opportunistes et à tout ce
qu'on avait absolument pas dû pendant la
campagne et qui venait de passer un
moment avec nous qui vous a le plus
marqué dans sa descente des champs
elysées après son élection en complet
veston milieu de la foule en s'arrêtant
on avait vraiment l'impression comme il
l'avait dit que commencer une nouvelle
ère politique et ça a été véritablement
une nouvelle ère politique pendant son
septennat
il fait terminer mal et aussi parce que
les français avaient envie d'alternance
et déjà il avait été hué maigrement 114
président mitterrand avait déjà été au
deuxième tour en 65 à 80 c'était pas
vraiment reçu 10 corps même si au bout
de sept ans un président est par nature
fatigué il y avait aussi une envie
d'alternance politique que le président
mitterrand a su à ce moment d'un carnet
merci beaucoup
dominique bussereau de votre témoignage
et devraient être avec nous une tout
peut-être une dernière question
puisqu'on devrait rendre l'antenne déjà
depuis 5 minutes mais jean louis
bourlanges
est-ce qu'il ya pas aussi un autre
paradoxe c'est que finalement il ya
aussi vous dites c'est la gauche qui
s'est mobilisé c'est ces jeunes auxquels
il a donné le droit de vote auraient
voté à gauche et qui qui ont voté
mitterrand de toute façon mais est-ce
que si elle le fait que toute la
politique de
valéry giscard d'estaing en particulier
à politique sociétale dans les années
durant son septennat ont fait que toute
la droite non plus s'est pas mobilisée
pour nous je crois que justement c'est
c'est la thèse assez classique qui est
la thèse de terrebonne ford françois
google une grande autorité en
politologie qui disait cela qui disait
c'est la droite il lui a manqué je ne
crois pas je crois que ce qui lui a
manqué c'est la fraction de la gauche
qu'il avait su détaché en 74 qu'il avait
surtout su détaché en 78 car vous voyez
bien que en 78 qui conquit il maintient
sa majorité législative de très près à
cause des politiques la politique
sociétal qui l'amenait à cause de
l'image et à cause d'eux il ya tout un
tas de gens qui seraient tentés par vote
réalisé voter à gauche qui craignent le
parti communiste alors ce qui fait en 79
ils changent d'idée et là il il adopte
une attitude beaucoup plus conservatrice
sur la peine de mort sur des choses
comme ça ils refusent ils refus c'est
une erreur de un statut pour les radios
locales ce qui aurait beaucoup séduit
les jeunes il ne pousse et c'est ça
qu'il fait perdre la politique vis-à-vis
des médias où il est resté quand même
assez n'a pas voulu faire un statut les
radios locales alors que c'est mitterand
qui était quand même c'est à dire est
qu'il a fait après ça a été un autre
départ ça renvoie
définition que j'aimais ce quart des
saints donner de lui-même et disait je
suis un traditionnaliste qui aiment le
changement
alors ce changement il avait des limites
c'était pas et il disait très bien quand
je lui ai demandé quels étaient s'il
avait été réélue quels étaient les
grandes réformes je vais poser la
question aussi agent cerisaie quête à
son ami et son conseiller
ils étaient tous les deux en fait non et
ça recoupe effectivement votre
explication c'était fait il n'y avait
pas de wii cet effet est en fait dans
son esprit il s'agissait surtout de
faire franchir un nouveau pas sur le
plan européen cet été ça mais en ce qui
concerne les réformes est considéré que
ce qu'il avait à faire avait été fait
j'avais tout fait que maintenant il
suffit de vivre il ya une autre
déception dont on n'a pas parlé mais on
dans lesquels on revient largement sans
le figaro c'est sa défaite aux élections
régionales en 2004 en auvergne ou qu'il
a il a dit c'est peut-être une défaite
qu'il alla - digérer puisque c'était un
des bilans les gants bilan à la tête de
la région viennent bien que c'est parce
qu'il faut que je dise ça parce que ça
va lui faire d'aller à lille ou encore
une minute à imaginer qu'il avait acheté
un château avec sa famille en auvergne
avait racheté le château d'estaing pour
en faire une fondation qui est
d'ailleurs très bien et on voyait qu'il
avait une certaine amertume d'avoir été
congédié c'est ce qu'on appelle le
mandat de trop il était déjà la sienne
et il avait 78 ans
il préfère d'ailleurs pierre mongin lui
avait dit que celle qui risquait d'être
battue où il y est allé quand même et
alors ils n'étaient pratiquement plus
les pieds en auvergne un jour il m'a dit
les aveyronnais ce sont des des
auvergnats qui serait aimable qui
effectuera tout en restant est mal le
château d'estaing qui était en aveyron
merci beaucoup pour cette année avec dot
eric roussel je rappelle votre
livres valéry giscard d'estaing c'est
aux éditions de l'observatoire vous avez
contribué également aux grandes figures
de la droite et on n'a pas parlé du
rapport entre giscard d'estaing le
général de gaulle mais c'est abordé dans
ce livre les grandes figures de la
droite qui est également
vous pouvez retrouver également une
contribution de jean louis bourlanges
sur valéry giscard d'estaing on se
retrouve tout à l'heure dans point de
vue à 17 heures on reviendra également
sur l'héritage politique de giscard dans
un instant le toc
yves thréard soit le ministre marc
fesneau